to politics now and we are still waiting
for results in three key Senate races
this morning races that could determine
control of Congress let's go through
them in Nevada senator Catherine Cortez
masto Trails her Republican Challenger
Adam laxalt but she is gaining on him as
more votes come in and are counted in
Arizona Senator Mark Kelly's lead has
grown over his Republican Challenger
that's Blake Masters and down in Georgia
we do have an outcome of sorts Senator
Raphael Warnock and Herschel Walker are
headed to a runoff in December after
neither candidate got above 50 percent
of the vote Ed O'Keefe is at the White
House for us where President Biden had
something to say about these results Ed
he seems to have beat the odds good
morning he sure has Tony good morning
and he's pleased with what he's seen so
far even as he's preparing to return to
the possibility of divided government he
says he's not willing to compromise with
Republicans on things like lowering
taxes for high earners or revamping
Social Security but since he understands
the negotiations are needed on other
things because Americans are hurting and
anticipating progress
while the press and the pundits are
predicting a giant red wave
it didn't happen President Biden praised
his party's performance in the midterm
elections and said he wouldn't change a
thing in his approach to governing
despite Republicans picking up seats I'm
prepared to work in my Republican
colleagues
the American people have made clear I
think that they expect Republicans to be
prepared to work with me as well the GOP
still needs to win two of the three
razor-thin Senate races in Arizona
Nevada or Georgia to take control of the
Senate so I want to tell y'all
if you can hang in hang in there a
little bit longer Georgia Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker is
returning to the campaign Trail today
with a bus tour and rally head of a post
Thanksgiving run-up against Democratic
senator Rafael Warnock mom we brought a
friend he's once again making aggressive
fundraising appeals as the runoff
campaign begins our work begins now
let's get America back on track even
with control of the house still
undecided minority leader Kevin McCarthy
officially launched his bid for speaker
Wednesday telling colleagues they'll
have what they need to go toe-to-toe
with the Executive Branch the president
and McCarthy spoke by phone late
Wednesday Mr Biden says he doesn't
believe Americans want the GOP to launch
investigations into the business
dealings of his son Hunter Biden I think
the American people will look at all of
that for what it is it's just I'm almost
comedy and looking ahead to 2024 the
president said it's his intention to run
again despite recent exit polls showing
more than 2 3 words don't want him to do
so he says a formal announcement is
likely coming early next year I don't
feel any any hurry one way or another
what to make that judgment
by the way the president said he's
looking forward to the potential
Republican primary between former
president Donald Trump and Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis he heads tonight
to a climate change conference in Egypt
and other Summits in Southeast Asia
there's one other result from Tuesday
night still hanging in the balance
there's a closely watched House race out
in Colorado you may remember the name
congresswoman Lauren bobert a pretty
strong pro-trump conservative in the
house she is currently trailing her
Democratic opponent by just a few dozen
votes she had predicted a red wave on
Tuesday night so did a lot of other
people that's not panning out Tony
no it sure isn't Ed thank you very much